If you want to be a true reborn Christian,
you need to follow Jesus Christ.
Because He is the truth, the Word of God.
John 1:1: In the beginning was the
Word, and the Word was with God.
And the Word was God.
If you follow Him - if you
truly love Jesus Christ with everything
that is in you - you will obey His Word.
John 14:15 says if you love Me,
you will keep My commandments.
Please listen to me today.
You cannot just follow certain parts
of scripture, certain parts of the Bible that
fit in with your lifestyle and leave the rest.
You either commit to God fully and change
your lifestyle according to scripture,
or you're deceiving yourself and you're a lukewarm
Christian, which means you're a fake Christian.